[Music]
[Applause]
Robert Ory Big Shot Bob seven-time NBA
champ and the Big Shot Bob podcast he
works for the Lakers Spectrum sports
analyst and he joins us this morning
Robert good to talk to you again what
did you see on the elbow with Anthony
Davis what was your initial thought
um I thought at first that he got his
eye hit and then you could see closely
that it hit him like in the corner of
his eye and I was just worried about you
know if he got hit in the temple or
something like that where he might have
a concussion so hopefully he's fine
because you know every player has been
hit in the eye under the basket and it
hurts really bad so hopefully you know
that's
something you know that's not going to
keep him prevented from playing in the
next game well if he has a concussion
according to the concussion protocol
he's gonna sit out 48 uh 48 Hours he
wouldn't be able to play Friday night
yeah I know and that's that's the thing
that we worried about uh and so I just I
just because you don't want anything
like this to happen in a great series
like this because he's playing extremely
well
um he's showing you why he should be one
considered one of the best defensive
players in the game and you just want to
see him back on the court because think
about it all the injuries he's had
throughout his career in them as bad as
people talk about him he didn't want him
to go out like this so the Lakers will
go out like this because of something
like this yeah and if you like you I
understood playing your guys but if
you're down by a certain number of
points
do you then put those guys on the bench
I thought around the five minute Mark if
you're down by you know 12 14 15 maybe
LeBron and A.D sit down
do you think that yeah they would have
been okay with that I think they've been
okay with that because they still had a
chance when ad without the game um but
you know the thing about is when you
play in Golden State and Golden State
and you try to match them three for
three and you can't do it because they
said they wanted the best shooting well
they are the best shooting guards of all
time and so you can't match them you
gotta you know play downhill like
Draymond did
um like Wiggins did and try to get
points in the paint and the Lakers
didn't do that and that's why the Golden
State Warriors were able to win that
game
why is Anthony Davis's pain tolerance
questioned
I think because when you have a guy with
this much talent you think about it
there's nothing this guy can't do on the
court and it's frustrated when he's not
on the court so I think people just
nitpick and say you know he has this he
has that but if you go back and look at
all his injuries they've all been you
know bad injuries bad luck injuries and
you know you can't you can't you know
you step on someone's foot and you twist
your ankle you know you can't get mad
about that but nobody talks about Kawhi
Paul George or any of those guys Chris
Paul these guys get hurt but it's they
always focus on KD I know I said A.D
because we expect so much out of AD and
it's not fair to him I don't think well
he's on the Lakers that's why it matters
if Kawhi was a Laker then people would
care about that or Chris Paul was with
the Lakers if you're with the Lakers if
you're with LeBron then we care more
about what you do or don't do that brand
and playing with the king is bright boy
so you got to step up at all times how
would you defend Steph Curry
um I think they're doing the right job
in defending him I think that um like I
said Wiggins and Draymond got up because
Steph can kill you from three you have
to you know it was weird how LeBron
followed him to the bench that's the way
you have to play it you you said your
job is to stay in front of the staff
stay connected at all times go over the
top of screens and whoever's making the
screen you better get up there and help
and make somebody else beat you because
Steph is just so dangerous and you can't
go underneath the screen no
but is there any okay as far as we all
know he's the greatest shooter of all
time who's the second greatest shooter
of all time his teammate
That's it man you know and you know and
the crazy part is about is we talk about
Steph's ability to shoot but if you know
step is a 100 and Clay is a 99.9 right
behind him and I think we kind of forget
about that because we missed him for the
last two seasons with injuries but he's
still one of the greatest Shooters to
ever play this game and think about it
because his name is game six clay and so
in game six we're gonna see if he can
stick up to that name but to me he's the
second greatest shooter of all time and
I'm third
okay game on the line would you pass it
to Steph Curry
I like that
would you pass it to Clay no I believe
in myself man if I'm double team I might
okay would you pass it to Jordan
uh uh no I don't think there's anybody
that would pass government myself good I
like them we're talking to Robert Ory
seven-time NBA champ uh you know you
start to look at careers here and I've
mentioned this isn't really a rivalry
between LeBron and Steph correct I mean
it's a it's a rivalry for greatness on
the greatness list yes but I don't think
there's a heated rivalry actually
between these two franchises but if
Steph wins he can move up
LeBron's not moving up from where he is
would you say he's second greatest
player of all time behind Mike
I I say I say that I say he is you know
the upper echelon you know he could be
first some days he can be second some
days but because I played against both I
would have to go with MJ it's not this
to LeBron it's just I just think when
you look at the body of work that MJ had
put in over the short amount of time
that he kind of gets you know a foot
ahead of him but you know if Steph wins
I still I think people you know I'ma say
this and it's probably gonna bite me in
the butt that's like saying I'm better
than Charles Barkley you know I hate him
because he went to Auburn that's just a
little joke because I went to Alabama
um he's still a better player than I was
I got seven championships you know I got
you know that's you know the late great
Kobe Bryant Shaquille O'Neal a large one
I have more championships than all those
guys but I'm not betting them you can't
really just judge a player by the
championship I played on better teams
than all of those guys that's why I have
seven championships and it's not tennis
where you're going to individual Sport
and we like always like the great guys
on how many chips they want in that case
you know I'm the ninth greatest player
[Laughter]
and it's just being reality and I think
people always say oh well he gets this
chip no you know if you look at what
LeBron has to do over his career he's
had to carry more teams than Steph ass
because you got clay you got Draymond
you think you got defensive player of
the year
um you got two uh with three All-Stars
and one team LeBron usually had maybe
one of the All-Star with him you know
except when he went to Miami but I just
think you just can't judge players by
the chips that they want Draymond Green
a Hall of Famer
um I think he is anytime you win an
award like defensive player of the year
I I think you can you know you should be
put in the Hall of Fame and let's be
honest he's a champion he's won five
chips he's he's been he's he's he
started a dynasty you know until they
got Draymond and still he started
deboing everybody you know he's he's
helped that franchise Winship so he has
to throw him in the hall yeah it's
always tricky when you're I I think he's
a Hall of Famer but you know you're a
really good player on a really good team
he's he's been recognized individually
whether it's you know second Team all
NBA or Defensive Player of the Year how
would you describe does anybody compare
to jokic that you played against
uh no um if you watch the way yoki's
plays his vision you know it it would he
would almost be like a sabonis the
you're not dishonest opponents up his
dad
um the way he played back in the day
before he came to the states and if you
have to go back and look at the old tape
of him where he can handle the rock he
could pass you know when he got to this
to the United States and started playing
with Portland you saw older sabones but
his passing skills were still tremendous
so I think that's the only person you
can compare him to because if you look
out through the history of Biggs most of
the bigs in my generation and before my
generation they were straight post
players you know you could have some
that could pass yeah but not like this
and I think he is in in a realm by
himself
you join the Lakers I think during the
middle of Kobe's rookie season correct
first impression was what
the first impression of Cody was this
guy's intense he was an 18 year old kid
he's intense and what I say about that
is we we didn't shoot around you know
shoot arounds when you've been in League
alone you walk through it he's like
going through screens hard he's getting
up for sweat and they're like hey man
calm down but you can see right then he
wanted to be great not good but great
and and the thing also about him is if
you tell him he's not good at something
he's going to be in the gym the next day
working on he don't care if you're the
best man on the team or the worst man
because he wanted to prove people wrong
and you know think about it when you
come in and uh he's not going to be that
good he's not going to be this and he
was always trying to prove through
people wrong and he did it man he was
you know when you talk about the
greatest you know you can go some days
where he's number one and MJ might be
number two LeBron might be three he
should be always talking that character
that category as one of the best players
ever played this game also because think
about it he copied the guy we call the
best player of all time he copied him to
a t so why not him being the best of all
time yeah I think it's interesting you
bring that up but I also think Jordan
made Kobe greater that if Kobe didn't
have Mike
then you know what's that motivation
like who am I trying to chase and it
always felt like he he always had that
I'm I'm chasing Jordan LeBron is too but
Kobe was more like Mike he wanted to be
Mike but I do think Mike being as great
as he was gave Kobe that incentive that
that that's the guy I I want to be or be
better than I think he strived to have
the greatness like Mike I don't think he
really wanted to be like Mike I think he
wanted all the accolades Mike had got he
wanted to be considered the greatest
like Mike because I think at the end of
the day every ball player wants to just
be themselves but they want to be you
know acknowledged for their
accomplishments and knowledge for their
skill set another for the body of work
that they play in this game when you
think about it Kobe he put in a lot of
work you know he went through a lot of
injuries and had a lot of adversities
but you know he was able to go from
number eight to 24 and think about it
the number eight was it Brash young guy
that nobody liked in the league you know
only his teammates and then he went to
24 where guys started going towards him
and you know asking him for advice and
it was a different type of person that
you saw when he got older and I think
you know if you look at eight and 24 you
put them together you're one of the
greatest players ever played this game
if I could take away your seven titles
don't do that but I put you but I you
make it the into the Hall of Fame but
you don't have rings
so you can have a Hall of Fame career or
you can have seven titles I mean I
really have seven titles because at the
end of the day Hall of Fame don't give
you anything for it you know there are
people in the Hall of Fame that you
don't even know who they are and I don't
care about the Hall of Fame even though
I feel like I should be in it but I
don't care about it you know that's
probably bite me in the butt too but at
the end of the day it's a team sport I
done I've done something a lot of
players would never do I've done things
that are only a few players have done
and you know I would just thinking about
this day yes yesterday I set a record
for the most threes made consecutively
in a in a in a playoff game and there's
so many things that I've done in the NBA
and that my teammates love me I only
have a few teammates that hate me and
that's the 12 guys from from the Phoenix
Suns but I've had a great I had a great
career man I don't you know the Hall of
Fame is something that all my friends
and family think I deserve but I still
would take the seven championships any
day over wondering a Hall of Fame room
if you got any of those championship
rings in that room no they're they're in
office I mean in my safe what is I mean
what's the Jersey you have over your
right shoulder that no no
oh that's my Gary Carter Jersey
um I was a huge Gary Carter fan what um
yes when I was growing up it's the show
called the baseball Bunch that usually
come on I play baseball remember that
show yeah and Gary Carter said um he
used to choke up on the bat and I went
out and Little League game I had two
home runs a triple and a double and I
remember that to this day and I I and I
became a huge hugest Gary Carter fan
that's when he was with the Expos and
then he got traded to the Mets and he
heard that story and he before he passed
away he signed the jersey for me and
gave it to me so I keep it I travel with
it because that you know me for someone
to hear your story and say thank you it
means a lot because there are a lot of
great athletes that can hear these
stories and just you know wave and keep
moving but I'm I'm a huge you know Gary
Carter fan you know God Rest his soul
did did Shaq used to run around naked
when he was with the Lakers
can you confirm that story Robert that
is a that is a true story we if we are
getting ready for practice we one day
and we like where's Shaq and all of a
sudden he just run them to the court
with just his shoes and socks on butt
naked and then runs right off the court
that was Dave that was the days before
camera phones and you you know you it's
also a a picture of him standing beside
Rick um with his shorts and everything
pulled up in his butt cheeks
you know
everybody Shack though he was a
character he he kept it like but it's
not many guys that can turn the switch
on go from being funny to being a
monster on the court and he was one of
those guys that could flip that switch
really quick go from being a silly guy
funny loving guy to a guy who would you
know knock your head off but I always
wonder and I I thought that uh you know
three titles but that we would look back
on what they should have won
like how couldn't Shaq have been the
fun-loving guy and coexisted with Kobe
I think so I think you know if you look
back at the you know the Laker team that
lost to Detroit they were missing a lot
of things you know it was missing guys
like Rick Fox myself that kind of kept
that team together because we could go
to Kobe and talk to me to go to Shaq and
talk to him and we can bring the team
together and when you bring in Outsiders
like Carl Malone and Gary Payton not
saying that they they didn't have the
same relationship I'm not saying they
were bad for the organizations they have
the same relationship that we had with
Chad and Kobe because think about most
of us has been there for seven years
with those guys and so he was able to
talk and keep things together and I hate
that they broke up that team even though
they went to the finals they broke up
that team you know they didn't give us a
chance you know we three-peated and then
we lost to a great team in the San
Antonio Spurs and it's all their old
let's break them up you know and but I I
it's a it just add pieces to what you
have they literally broke up a team and
I hate that they did it but you know
Kobe got back on top Shaq got back on
top but not before I did
Tim Duncan a top 10 player of all time
uh yes I think Tim Duncan is one of the
greatest players ever played this game
we kind of starting to forget about him
because his game was born and basic
which ain't nothing wrong with that you
know think about it Tim probably could
have did the stuff that Jokers did but
he didn't have to he kind of did sub
distracted but he didn't have to because
he had a lot of great players with him
and at the end of the day because you
know I I look at two guys throughout
this career Tim and dream they're very
quiet guys you don't see it you don't
hear anything about them you don't see
anything about them and so we kind of
tendency forget about the people who
don't who don't make noise and to me
those two guys are always going to be
top ten but we forget about them because
we don't hear anything about it we don't
talk about but we're always going to
compare oh he's Tim Duncan like oh he
got the footwork of dream but these two
guys are probably the two of the best
big men ever to play the game no I love
dream I did I just I thought he had he
had a point guard uh footwork he had
touch uh just a big big big fan of of
Akeem Elijah yeah he was Joel and B
before Joel and beat yeah yeah he was he
was a lot of these Centers before these
centers you felt like uh great to talk
to you
yes he was yeah he wasn't as big as you
thought you know uh covering those
Houston NBA finals and you're like they
listing man like 611 but it didn't feel
like he was six eleven no no not when
I'm six nine six ten I'm living dead in
his eyes
yeah but try guarding him on the post
yeah exactly uh great to talk to you
Robert thanks for joining us and uh it's
always a pleasure thanks for always
having me on I appreciate you got a lot
of love for you that's Robert oring
I'd probably be a better shooter than me
but uh I don't like the challenge I love
the fact that hey you can throw it to
Steph or you take it yourself
well your name is Big Shot Bob
he's one of the few guys who can get
away with that